[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
mardi 31 octobre voici le programme de
ce soir attention au vent violent la
tempête kiarane qui vient de la Bretagne
devrait toucher les yelines cette nuit
des rafales dev vent à jusqu'à 90 kmh
sont attendus dans le secteur de mant-la
jolie soyez prudent plus d'informations
en début d'émission le centre commercial
one nation Paris outlet des clés sous
boois faê ces 10 ans pour l'occasion
deux grands chefs sont venus faire des
shows culinaires jusqu'au 5 novembre
vous pouvez également profiter des
nombreuses animations présentes sur le
site et comme d'habitude le mardi votre
page culture exposition d'art
contemporain à Versailles visite
théâtralisée du château de Monte Cristo
encore toiri lumière sauvage les
activités ne manquent pas dans le
département découvrez toutes nos idées
pour finir vos vacances de la toussin en
beauté enfin l'invité du 78 en 2uxème
partie d'émission le maire de trappe
ALIR Rabé était présent au comité
interministériel des villes avec la
première ministre à Chanteloup lesévgne
ce dernier Espérit des mesures fortes en
faveur des quartiers populaires il en
ressort mitigé il nous explique pourquoi
mais tout de suite on fait le point sur
les informations à retenir dans les
ivelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel el midoro
bonsoir bonsoir On commence ses
informations avec la tempête carariane
qui est attendue dans les ivelines tout
à fait Mathilde arrivée du car
nord-ouest du pays la tempête karane va
commencer à souffler dès ce soir sur
notre département des vents environ 40
km/h sont attendus mais c'est surtout
pour la T 5 que des bourrasques à 80 à
kmèh se feront ressentir dans la soirée
pour le jeudi ce sera très révent avec
des rafales à près de 90 km/h le reste
de la semaine des pointes à 70 km/h sont
attendu face au risque de chute d'arbr
plusieurs communes du département ont
décidé de fermer leur parc pendant ces
journées mouvementées prenez donc garde
en sortant de chez vous ce n'est qu'à
partir du lundi 6 novembre que
l'intensité devrait diminuer
progressivement demain c'est le début du
mois de novembre un mois important pour
ceux qui essayent d'arrêter de fumer dès
demain démarre la 8e édition du mois
sans tabac un défi collectif national
sur 30 jours pour en finir avec cette
mauvaise habitude aujourd'hui c'est le
dernier jour pour s'inscrire
gratuitement sur le site internet de
l'opération si vous décidez d'y
participer vous recevraz un kit d'arrêt
du tabac une consultation avec un
professionnel et l'entraide de toute une
communauté grâce aux réseaux sociaux
rappelons qu'arrêz de fumer pendant un
mois multiplie par 5 les chances de
cesser définitivement une bonne occasion
de rejoindre les 115000 participants
déjà inscrits on poursuit ces
informations avec une tribune qui a été
signée par 61 députés Renaissance dont
l'une et ivelinoise ces personnalités
politiques de la majorité présidentielle
appelle à la protection des populations
civiles victimes du conflit
israélo-palestinien dans le quotidien
l'opinion parmi les signataires la
députée de la 7e circonscription
desésivel nadiae qui appelle à une trêve
humanitaire à Gaza dans leur tribune les
députés écrivent je cite une vie
palestinienne vaut une vie française qui
vaut une vie israélienne ce texte
intervient après l'extension des
opérations militaires dans la région on
va désormais parler de football hier
soir se tenait la 67e cérémonie du
Ballon d'Or au théâre du châtelé à Paris
et Kyan Mbappé a terminé sur le podium
et bien que le joueur des Bleus n'est
pas reçu la prestigieuse distinction il
a tout de même terminé à la 3e place
devant lui Lionel Messi et Harling
alland sur sa page Instagram il a tenu à
féliciter le joueur argentin pour son
titre pour Rael attaquant de 24 ans du
pariss-germain a été formé à l'Institut
national du football de Claire Fontaine
dans les Yvelines le buteur devra
patienter au minimum jusqu'à l'année
prochaine pour espérer décrocher le
Graal et bien merci beaucoup Michel
elmidoro pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une information ou une image près
de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news élu d'opposition att trppé
vice-président du conseil régional
d'île-de-fance Man nasrou est candidat à
la présidence de la fédération l' des
Yvelines dans cette élection il do il
doit affronter Philippe benasaya le
résultat sera connu le 27 novembre dans
cet entretien avec Patrice carmou il
revient sur la situation de la droite
dans le département et en France il
s'oppose également avec force au projet
de loi immigration présenté par Gérald
daranan ce que je vois moi c'est que il
y a des choses qui fondent une société
des valeurs commune une culture commune
des références communes et que ça se
délite voilà c'est ce que je constate je
constate qu'il y a un délitement de ce
qui fait qu'une société peut tenir
ensemble et ça passe parce qu'il y a
l'entrisme d'un certain nombre
d'identitaires religieux il y a
l'influence aussi de la radicalisation
des de l'anrisme des islamistes qui ont
un agenda politique sur malheureusement
certaines populations qui essaient de
les conduire vers une lecture qui est
contre la République et contre la France
c'est vraiment ce que je constate et je
je pense qu'on est nombreux à le
constater donc oui il y a le constater
dans des villes comme trap ENF vous êtes
par exemple ou mais évidemment
évidemment et ce n'est pas simplement
moi qui vous le dis vous pouvez
rencontrer beaucoup d'habitants de
trappe qui vous diront que ils ont le
sentiment que ce qui faisait et bien la
vie en commun est en train de
disparaître que le fait religieux prend
le pas sur sur le fait national sur le
fait qu'on est forme d'abord une
communauté nationale je vous donne un
exemple à trappe il n'y a plus de
charcuterie depuis 2015 dans une ville
de 32000 habitants ça peut paraître
anecdotique vous pourvez me dire c'est
l'offre et la demande mais comment
voulez-vous qu'il y ait de la mixité
quand vous avez des gens qui nont plus
le S sentiment qu'ils peuvent trouver
dans leur ville et bien une offre qui
s'adapte à eux et donc ces gens-là
partent ils partent et on concentre
ainsi et bien les mêmes populations qui
en plus ne sont pas en demande moi j'ai
beaucoup de trapistes de toute
confession qui vous disent qu'ils
veulent de la mixité qu'ils ne veulent
pas être dans espèce de getto
identitaire où ils sont constamment
enfermés dans un discours de
radicalisation mais bien sûr mais oui il
des concentration oui mais il y a des
gens qui l'ont fait exprès il y a des
élus de gauche et d'extrême gauche qui
ont voulu concentrer les logements
sociaux dans les mêmes qutiers pour se
constituer à vie un électorat captif il
porte aujourd'hui une lourde
responsabilité et vous pourrez retrouver
l'intégralité de cette émission verry
yvelinoise person sur notre antenne et
nos réseaux sociaux direction les clés
sousbois à présent le centre commercial
one nation Paris outlet faite ces 10 ans
et pour l'occasion il propose des
animations tout au long des vacances de
la toussin animation culinaire jeux pour
enfant une panoplie d'activités pour les
grands et les petits c'est le reportage
de Clara de Frutos et de
et je vais vous proposer aussi de TR de
saues différentes pour accompagner cette
recettean
empanadas végétarienne à la patate douce
c'est la recette proposée par Juan arm
chef cuisinier colombien et ancien
participant de l'émission Top Chef un
grand classique de la street fot
colombienne revisité sous l'œil attentif
des visiteurs moi ce que je préfère
vraiment c'est les gens qui viennent il
réussit à
réunir et une quantité de gens juste
exceptionnel vraiment pendant la démo
j'ai levé la tête et à un moment je me
suis senti chez moi il y avait que des
sourir accueillant que des gens qui
étaient là prêts à écouter prêts à
déguster prêt à passer un énorme et et
un bon moment donc c'était vraiment je
pense un souvenir que j'oublierai jamais
l'animation a duré 2 he pour le plus
grand plaisir des visiteurs c'est très
varié alors déjà moi je suis une grande
gourmande donc j'étais ravie de pouvoir
assister au show culinaire du chef Juan
donc voilà on s t se régaler et puis bon
c'est hyper dynamique des jeux pour
enfants des stands culinaires une
variété d'animation est proposée par le
Centre pour célébrer ses 10 années
d'existence avec sa clientèle 10 ans
s'est passé super vite après c'est vrai
que fréquemment il y a toujours des
animations qui sont qui sont faites ici
donc c'est cool c'était très bien ça
amène des activités aux enfants et ça le
permet de passer le temps pendant que
nous on est en train de faire les
magasins en tant que parents en 10 ans
le centre a accueilli près de 5 million
de visiteurs il compte 98 enseignes et
plus de 400 marques les animations
continueront jusqu'au 5
novembre allez c'est l'heure d'ouvrir
une page culture à présent dans votre
[Musique]
78 et on débute cette page culture avec
une exposition l'artiste Dianne Benoît
Duray hypnotise lesespacherichot à
Versailles jusqu'au 3 décembre vous
pouvez pouvez découvrir les œuvres de la
peintre qui sont axé sur la lumière et
la couleur sable tissu peinture à
l'huile son art fait appel au sens
attention à ne pas vous faire
[Musique]
hypnotiser jusqu'au 3 décembre l'espace
Richaud de Versailles propose aux
visiteurs une nouvelle exposition d'art
contemporain baptisé hypnose elle invite
à se perdre dans les dégradés de couleur
et de
lumière
[Musique]
pour se faire l'artiste Dianne Benoît
Duray a imaginé 10 tableaux ainsi qu'un
cercle de sable coloré installé au
centre de la rotonde de l'ancien hôpital
Royal alors disque sablé c'est du coup
une installation insitu c'estàdire je
l'ai vraiment pensé en fonction du lieu
en fonction du mouvement du spectateur
on puisse apparaître des des impressions
colorimétriques très différentes je
trouvais que c'était vraiment
intéressant l'artiste a réalisé cette
œuvre en 3 jours à l'aide de 400 kg de
sable à l'étage ce sont 50 m de teinture
peinte qui recouvre les murs pour mieux
faire apparaître la coupole à caisson
inspirée du panthéon de r
elles sont accompagnées d'une création
sonore de François de laamar pour
imprégner un peu plus le visiteur et le
faire entrer en
hypnose
[Musique]
j'avais envie de travailler sur le
caractère sur la dimension
expérientielle de de la peinture quand
je dis expérientielle c'est vraiment de
l'ordre de l'optique du sensoriel et du
physique parce que je pense que vraiment
la peinture a a ce pouvoir là sur nous
et et en sens là hypnose c'est venu
assez assez naturellement pour compléter
la visite l'artiste peintre de 34 ans a
sélectionné une une dizaine de ces
tableaux les plus récents ces toiles
cherchent à répondre à une question qui
l'obsède est-ce que la peinture
peut-être source de lumière un travail
délicat mais qui peut faire toute la
différence et comme chaque mardi nous
partons à la rencontre d'une salle de
spectacle du territoire ce soir c'est
l'espace Alphonse d'udé à coanière qui
vous donne trois raisons d'aller voir le
champ de bataille un seul en scène drôle
et dynamique qui parle à tout le monde
regardez bonjour je suis Gwenola bigouin
directrice de l'espace Alphonse d'udé à
coanière aujourd'hui je vais vous donner
trois bonnes raisons d'aller voir le
spectacle champ de
[Musique]
bataille c'est un se en scène qui aborde
l'adolescence et la crise de la
quarantaine c'est donc un spectacle
drôle rythmé et émouvant deuxème raison
c'est un spectacle
familial les adolescents comme les
adultes s'y retrouveront pourront rire
d'eux-mêmes et de leurs proches donc en
l'occurrence des parents ou des enfants
la troisème raison c'est un spectacle
belge donc un gage de qualité en temps
normal et qui plusé qui a été nominé en
2020 au prix meterling qui sont les
Molières belges nous lui avons pas
montré la mer nous l' avons pas appris à
faire du vélo nous lui avons pas torché
le derrière non nous sommes arrivés le
jour de son 15e anniversaire pour lui
dire de ramasser ses mouchoirs et de
mettre ses slips dans le bacalage sale
un enfant il ne faudrait jamais lui
permettre de dépasser 12 ans grand
maximum après les emmerdes
commenc c'était donc les trois bonnes
raisons d'aller voir le champ de
bataille le 17 novembre à 20h45 à
l'espace Alphonse
doudé
quelle est l'histoire du château de
Monte Cristo niché au cœur d'un parc de
3 hectares la demeure du célèbre
écrivain Alexandre Duma est peu connu
pourtant elle vaut le détour et pour
vous imprégner un peu plus du lieu et de
son histoire le château propose des
visites théâtralisées chaque dernier
dimanche du mois de quoi revivre
certaines scènes des Trois Mousquetaires
ou du compte de Monte Cristo Mélanie
poket et Gabriel Gontier ont suivi une
de ses
visites la vie au château de Monte
Cristo raconté par des personnages tout
droit sortis des œuvres d'Alexandre Duma
pardon je suis pas présenté je suisri
oui j'ai été marié avec Alexandre Duma
pendant 3 années le temps d'une journée
des comédiens costumés ont fait vivre
aux visiteurs une visite quelque peu
originale du célèbre château de
portmarli où Alexandre Duma a élu
domicile en 1847 pour fuir le tumulte de
la ville au travers de différ SC les
personnages des romans de Duma prennent
vie comme l'agréable cardinal de
Richelieu personnage du roman Les Trois
mousquetaires ah dis donc ils sont ai la
monarchie que
diriez-vous une enseigne dans mes gardes
cette année le thème des visites
théattralisé était la vente du château
de Duma après la Révolution l'écrivain
couvert de dette et contraint de vendre
sa demeure c'est de rendre un peu le
tout interactif ludique qu' soit un peu
accompagné qu' a du spectacle que ça
reste vivant ça leur permet vraiment
d'être impliqué dans la visite le fait
de les attraper comme ça avec des
personnages ça permet que même le moment
où nous on va pas être dans le château
où on leur laisse aussi le temps de
visite nécessaire ils vont être plus
curieux ils vont aller chercher des
détails et justement depuis 10 ans la
compagnie a conquis le public c'est une
excellente idée pour
pouvoir rythmer la visite parce
qu'effectivement c'est une œuvre
littéraire il y a beaucoup de d'articles
et de de choses à lire dans Le dans les
salles du musée et donc avec les c ça
permet de de casser le rythme c'est très
sympathique c'est bien fait c'est moi
j'ai j'ai bien rigolé ces visites
théatralisées sont organisées chaque
dernier dimanche du mois dernier
rendez-vous pour 2023 le 26 novembre
cette année la demeure d'Alexandre Duma
a déjà reçu plus de 30000 visites
et on termine cette page culture avec
une autre idée de sortie de idée de
sortie à faire durant les vacances de la
toussin alors que les journées
raccourcissent le zoo safari de toiri a
décidé d'illuminer vos fins de journée
avec le retour des lumières sauvages une
déambulation FÉRIQUE dans les jardins le
thème de cette année l'Asie c'est le
reportage de Mélanie Poké et de Clara de
Frutos
entré dans un monde enchanté les
lumières sauvages de Toir sont
installées un parcours d'un peu plus
d'un kilomètre à travers les jardins du
château pour voyager au cœur des grands
continents des peuples et de leur
écosystème c'est efférique c'est
vraiment magique on tombe complètement
en enfance on voit tous ces animaux
c'est c'est vraiment magnifique moi j'ai
bien aimé ça a l'air bien la la nouvelle
partie d'Asie qu'ils ont fait donc on va
aller découvrir ça je trouve ça
magnifique il a eu des améliorations
enfin des des changements par rapport
aux années précédentes ils ont ajouté
des scènes de vie avec des personnages
ça fait 2 3 ans qu'on vient avec ma
famille et en c'est de c'est toujours
aussi beau jusqu'au 10 mars 2024 le zoo
safari a choisi d'illuminer les fins de
journée avec une 6e édition de ces
lumières sauvages le thème de cette
année l'Asie un an de travail de
réflexion pour les équipes qui proposent
une nouveauté un renouveau avec encore
beaucoup plus d'immersion avec le
labyrinthe qui est complètement qui sera
complètement illuminé cette année et
puis derrière vous vous avez l'Asie qui
prend vie avec tous les animaux d'Asie
et juste derrière moi les bouddas aussi
les temples qui vont pouvoir animer
cette scène le parcours est agrémenté de
près de 3000 lanternes 75 % d'entre
elles sont restaurées chaque année un
souhait du site il ne vous reste plus
qu'à vous laisser
[Musique]
porter et c'est bientôt l'heure de
passer à l'invité du 78 mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions toujours
rester au sec selon météofance le ciel
devrait être nuageux mais avec quelques
éclaircis sur l'ensemble du territoire
ivelinois côté température compteé 11°g
à versaill et rambouillé 12°gr à Mantel
jolie et oudans dans l'après-midi la
pluie devrait faire son retour prévoyez
votre parapluie niveau température elle
fera 14°gr à Mantel jolie 13 à Houdan et
rouillé et 12 12 à Versailles et demain
ce sera la fête de la toussin c'est
l'heure à présente de passer à l'invité
du 78
[Musique]
vous en parlez dans l'émission d'hier
soir vendred vendredi dernier ellisabeth
borne était à Chantelou lesvin la
première ministre a annoncé plusieurs
mesures afin de répondre aux urgences
des quartiers prioritaires plusieurs
acteurs et élus locaux était présents
lors de cette rencontre dont alirabé le
maire de trappe ce dernier estime que
certaines mesures ne sont pas
suffisantes il a acceptter de répondre
aux questions de Régine ralèche et de
Julien Leroi vous venez toujours tout
juste de sortir du comité
interministériel des villes avec la
première ministre ellisabeth borne tout
d'abord quel bilan est-ce que vous en
faites est-ce que vous êtes satisfait ah
je ne peux pas dire que je suis
satisfait on a eu une série de mesures
parfois des mesurettes assez
artificielles qui ont été annoncées et
grainé é tout au long de 2 heures de
prise de parole des ministres alors je
regrette déjà un grand absent c'est les
habitants des quartiers politiques de la
ville cet exercice qui se limite à un
échange entre des élus des
institutionnels et le gouvernement ne
répond pas aux attentes des habitants
des quartiers populaires c'est ma
conviction il y a eu quelques annonces
qui sont positive dont on se réjouit
avec les maires de l'association ville
et banlieu qui regroupe les quartiers
politiques de la ville on a par exemple
des annonces autour de la généralisation
des cités éducatives qui permettront de
mettre plus de partenariat entre l'école
les villes l'État dans notre territoire
euh on a des annonces aussi qui sont
pour l'instant cosmétiqu mais dont on
attend de voir si elles peuvent porter
sur le territoire pour lutter contre la
ghettoisation notamment le fait
d'attribuer des logements aux familles
les plus pauvres dans les quartiers qui
sont déjà les plus pauvres ça contribue
à ghettoiser encore nos quartiers on
espère pouvoir en sortir mais il y a pas
de mesure de rupture il y a pas de
souffle il y a pas une ambition à la
hauteur de nos attentes et pour
l'instant je ne vois pas les ingrédients
qui permettrai d'éviter les situations
que nous avons connu il y a quelques
mois avec l'explosion de colère dans nos
cas quartier et à votre avis quelle est
aujourd'hui la première urgence à
prendre en compte ou peut-être les
premières urgences à prendre en compte
il y en a malheureusement plusieurs le
défi éducatif évidemment tant qu'on a
100000 enfants qui sortent du système
scolaire en étant déscolarisés sans
diplôme qui ne sont pas accompagnés à
partir de 16 ans et bien on continuera
de produire de la vulnérabilité de la
fragilité de l'échec de la frustration
du ressentiment et de la colère chez une
partie de notre jeunesse donc réussir à
être capable de lutter contre le
décrochage et contre l'échec scolaire
mais dès plus jeune âge c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut amplifier et renforcer
la question de l'emploi aussi est
évidemment un sujet majeur il faut
pouvoir apporter des emplois dans ces
quartiers permettre des débouchés y
compris pour ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément des grands diplômes et il faut
aussi à mon sens résoudre ce problème de
la mixité si on continue à avoir des
villes qui se spécialisent dans
l'accueil de la pauvreté et qui voi 60
70 80 % de leur population être en
situation de relative pauvreté avec des
logements sociaux concentrés toujours
dans les mêmes quartiers toujours dans
les mêmes villes et bien et on générera
toujours nos propres malheurs on peut
pas avoir des villes riches où les
riches vivent entre eux des villes
pauvres ù les pauvres vivent entre eux
ça c'est un défi que la France doit
relever mais ça demande plus que
quelques mesurettes annoncé un vendredi
matin et à l'issue du comité Catherine
arénou a dit qu'elle continuerait
d'espérer quelle estvous aujourd'hui
votre état d'esprit nous on n pas le
choix parce que vous savez la différence
entre les membres du gouvernement et et
les élus locaux c'est que nous on est au
contact quotidien avec la population si
nous on désespère la République est à
genou donc on continuera non seulement
d'espérer mais d'agir d'agir sur le
terrain avec des solutions qu'on invente
localement et qui parfois inspirent les
gouvernements et puis aussi d'exiger et
d'être attentif exigeant vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs publics pour que l'ensemble des
ministères l'ensemble de ce qu'on
appelle le droit commun mette les moyens
nécessaires dans nos quartiers je
rappelle que en matière d'éducation en
matière de sécurité en matière de
justice plusieurs rapports ont établi le
fait que dans nos quartiers il y a moins
de moyens de l'État donc il faut au
moins garantir le même les mêmes moyens
pour tous les habitants de notre pays et
nous localement on restera disponible
pour inventer des solutions et les
mettre en œuvre et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée
d'Halloween attention ne mangez pas trop
de bonbons moi je vous donne rendez-vous
jeudi prochain d'ici là prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous